you
a woman who said she was sexually
assaulted after getting in a lift is now
blaming the rate the ride-hailing giant
for allegedly mishandling her report
Allison Turkish is her name she claims
she was kidnapped at gunpoint by her
lyft driver back in 2017 and sexually
assaulted by at least two men she's
among five people who filed lawsuits
against lyft earlier this week nikki
batise has spoken to turkos nikki this
is very disturbing what did she tell you
good morning Gail it is Alison Turkish
told us the person she once was ceased
to exist after what she says happened to
her in 2017 she claims she hopped in a
lift after a night out with friends when
the driver locked the doors and wouldn't
let her out some viewers may find some
of what she describes disturbing a
minute that the gun gets pulled and is
so close to my face the first thought
that came to my mind was like I'm not
gonna get home safe and I'm probably not
gonna get home alive
Alison Turco says a lyft ride she took
in 2017
was only supposed to last around 15
minutes instead she says over the course
of 79 minutes she was kidnapped by her
driver driven from New York to New
Jersey and sexually assaulted by at
least two men what's the one word you
would use to describe how lyft has
treated you
callously according to Turco's recently
filed lawsuit a rape kit administered
afterward confirmed evidence of semen
from two men on the clothing she wore
that night in the suit she says she
initially blocked out what happened and
reported to lift only that her driver
had taken her outside of her route and
across state lines
you call lyft within 24 hours and what's
their response to your first report
their first response is that this never
happened the next day they send me an
email that says we've refunded to you 93
dollars and 99 cents we are still
charging me 12 dollars in 81 cents so
let's charge to me $12 in 81 cents to be
kidnapped across state lines gang-raped
and trafficked Turco says she filed a
police report after she was allegedly
raped this week the law firm
representing her filed five lawsuits and
says it currently represents around 68
women who claim to have been sexually
assaulted by lyft drivers just two weeks
ago 14 women filed suits against lyft
alleging it mishandled sexual assault
complaints and in some cases allow
drivers to continue to work the driver
was able to make a new profile update a
new profile photo and update a new name
and was still driving for a lift in a
statement lyft told CBS News what
Turco's describes is awful and something
no one should have to endure they added
this year alone they've launched 14 new
safety features including continuous
background check monitoring and in-app
emergency assistance but Turco says
she's not buying it it's just an attempt
of smoke and mirrors to once again
present an assumption of safety when
you're stepping into a car lyft told us
Turco's originally reported the incident
as an indirect route not a safety issue
the company says it deactivated Turco's
driver but wouldn't tell us when no one
has been arrested or charged for
assaulting Turco's and the FBI is now
handling the investigation some ways
that you can stay safe when using
ride-sharing apps are to be sure to
check
Car and Driver Information sit in the
backseat and share your location status
so your friends can follow along on the
app good information for all of us can't
get over the fact that she's still
charged for the ride $12 in 81 cents I'm
literally a big mistake maybe it's just
automated did she say why she didn't
originally report it as a safety issue
like many rape victims she couldn't
really remember exactly what happened
and sort of started coming back to her
and that's why Nikki thank you very much